alec castonguay chantal hébert paul
journée bonsoir bonsoir
évidemment faut se garder de faire des
comparaisons
trop savants dire verra voilà ça nous
donne la leçon de la campagne fédérale
tout de même ce matin alec castonguay
monsieur trudeau aurait aimé mieux
commenté une victoire libérale en
nouvelle écosse à tout prendre bien
évidemment surtout qu'en campagne
électorale tous les symboles sont montés
en épingle puis on essaie de voir toutes
sortes de de signes dans les feuilles de
thé et donc c'est clair qu'on aurait
souhaité que les libéraux qui étaient en
nouvelle-écosse quand même au moins une
vingtaine de points en avance au début
de la campagne l'emportent une vingtaine
de points en avance au début de la
campagne ah ouais au moins et même au
creux de l'été ses 28 points d'avancé le
libero la nouvelle écosse donc c'est
quand même un retournement de situation
important ceci dit et aussi beaucoup de
limites à la comparaison 1 d'abord ce
qui s'est passé en nouvelle-écosse ian
rankin qui était le plus jeune premier
ministre du canada en poste et est
nouveau c'est pas lui qui a présidé à la
gestion de la pandémie les libéraux labo
avait une bonne cote les gens avaient
apprécié leur gestion de la pandémie
mais c'est pas lui qu'on voyait côté du
médecin hygiéniste en chef de
nouvelle-ecosse testez-vous de maintenir
qui est lui à quitter c'était quelqu'un
qui était relativement peu connu yann
qui ne serait pas un joueur comme nom y
est un lieu très mauvaise campagne
électorale non seulement mauvais débat
mais s'est empêtrée dans quelques
difficultés personnelles alors à un
moment donné il ya aussi le fait que les
libéraux là bas on fait une mauvaise
campagne et sabin savait pas dit que les
libéraux d'être de suivre le même chemin
donc été quand même des limites à la
comparaison là oui effectivement il ya
des grandes firmes et quand même cette
règle kippen règles mais ce qu'on voyait
que le gouvernement sorte un bain
sortait gagnant mais l'oeil et ça ça
n'arrive pas cette fois-ci chantal
qu'il reste plus beaucoup de premiers
secours ap hier soir c'est un fardeau
pour d'avoir en temps jules pour la
première fois en ontario des vôtres
pietersen qui un jour gagner les
élections avait 10 ans perdant partiel
je vais jamais gagné campagne avec
partiellement je vais avoir pierre
trudeau cet albatros autour de bon alors
bonjour d'ambiance son allié libéral
je vais vous suggérer que oui c'est sûr
que justin trudeau avait pas de raisons
tu as bouazzi devant ce résultat mais
que quelque part il doit y avoir des
stratèges libéraux qui trouve quand même
leur compte et voici pourquoi c'est un
bon capelle à tous et libéraux qui sont
sur le terrain que c'est pas à qui la
victoire électorale et qui peuvent pas
se permettre de continuer à se prélasser
dans le jardin en buvant du lait et
blanc et en pensant que tout va bien
aller et que la victoire est dans le sac
et c'est un bon moment pour le rappeler
à tout le monde et peut-être au premier
ministre lui même qui
[Musique]
en sont un peu mollo oui entre la
dernière fois on a moins deux jours pour
juger cette fois ci mais la dernière
fois on se demandait si vous voulez
vraiment pas journée donc rappelle aux
libéraux que la défaite ça ça se peut
aussi la wii puis dans toute élection
les progressistes ont moins tendance à
voter donc c'est toujours un défi
particulier pour les libéraux et les
néo-démocrates et on le voit qu'un taux
de participation est plus faible latence
avantager les conservateurs et c'est
encore plus important cette élection si
parce que on sait pas dans quelle mesure
la quatrième banque doit pouvoir
dissuader des gens d'aller voter ce qui
est certain qu'ils vont voir rester chez
eux est ce que le vote postal qui va
centrer valoir est ce que ça va être
aussi populaire qu'on le souhaiterait
donc en ce sens cela c'est vrai que ça
peut être un rappel
bénéfique robot libéraux le dire de rien
tu rends pour acquis moi la seule leçon
que je tire raid de ce résultat en
nouvelle écosse ce que vous savez des
fois on dit que là on a l'impression
qu'à politique américaine est plus
intéressante mais ça reste du bipartisme
et il ya moins de mouvements alors qu'au
canada moi je trouve au contraire que
c'est plus intéressant il ya beaucoup de
parties puis ça bouge dans les campagnes
électorales est ce que je retiens de
cette campagne c'est que les sondages en
début de campagne c'est un polaroïd qui
veulent pas dire grand-chose au fort
parce que ça peut avoir changé c'est
justement c'est comme ça la raison pour
laquelle on joue c'est parce qu'on sait
pas à l'avancé qui va gagner c'est la
même chose en politique et même si les
libéraux sont en avance c'est quoi ils
normes comme avance
de quatre points de pourcentage et
justin trudeau serais très inquiet le 20
septembre c'est pas énorme et et chantal
et alec l'autre facteur qui a pas non
plus un enjeu qui convoie venir qui va
monopoliser toucha donc c'est encore
plus dangereux quand une élection où on
ne sait pas trop comment la définir
encore chantal a veillé tout et tous les
partis vont vous dire
à ce moment ci en 96 km kaboul allait
faire élire un gouvernement majoritaire
conservateur
les électeurs généralement dans les
campagnes déclenché commencent à
s'intéresser à la chose à que la rentrée
c'est la fed us pareil et les débats
cela dit il faut mentionner aussi parce
que c'est important que le premier
ministre désigné en nouvelle écosse donc
monsieur houston on verra pas sur des
tribunes avec et renault tour pour la
bonne et simple raison qui a passé les
trois dernières années a dit qu'il
n'était pas mort je suis parti
conservateur fédéral pour bien expliquer
aux électeurs de nouvelle écosse qu'en
votant pour lui votre épaule la sorte de
parti conservateur du gouvernement
fédéral est offerte campagne quand on
regarde sa campagne a fait campagne à
gauche du parti libéral la nouvelle
école juste d'argent ouais et sur le
même terrain en fait que justin trudeau
plutôt que sur le terrain des rondes
autour tellement qu'au débat des chefs
on lui a reproché d'avoir trop de bonnes
choses à dire sur justin trudeau
alec un petit mot là dessus sur ce ce
début de campagne qu'on essaie de
de dessiner qui n'est pas évident
jusqu'ici non s'était posée aussi comme
temps je me souviens de la campagne et
2019 le où on avait un ton très agressif
le évidemment entre les campagnes
conservatrices et libérales n'y avait
pas il n'y avait pas du tout d'affection
entre indochine et justin trudeau ce au
niveau du débat des chefs le très
acrimonieux d'ailleurs entre les deux
longs on est vraiment c'est comme si
tout le monde faisait sa campagne
séparément avec ses propres termes 11,9
pas la peine on a pas que les questions
des journalistes pour dire ah ben on en
voit une petite flèche à l'autre mais on
a l'impression que tout le monde est un
peu au réchauffement probablement comme
les électeurs on a un peu les deux pieds
sur le bord de la piscine ça risque
d'être une campagne en réalité le où
l'action va vous être dans une très
courte période de temps peut-être à
partir de la fin ou début septembre mais
j'ai presque comme une semaine un peu je
n'ai pas perdu parce qu'on est injuste
mercredi soit il reste encore du temps
mais c'est une semaine où j'ai pas
l'impression que le mouvement de
mouvement vous ouvrez la porte je vais
donner si vous me le permettez
l'adresse pour les gens qui veulent
envoyer des questions pour le débat des
chefs vous parler du débat 8 septembre
en français alors ces débats 20 21 ans
commercial radio canada.ca déjà il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous ont écrit
merci continuer de partout au canada
évidemment on vous lit et vous pourrez
donc
poser des questions directement aux
chefs lors de ce débat en français le 8
septembre
dany forte accusé d'agression sexuelle
cela a permis au chef en campagne de
rappliquer avait un gros malaise dans
les forces canadiennes font entendre les
chefs qu'on vient parler ensuite
on a vu un camouflage sur les
allégations d'inconduite sexuelle
à part le bio co de monsieur to do il y
a trois ans c'est totalement
inacceptable et c'est pourquoi on doit
voir une enquête indépendante on doit
voir un gel pour les promotions et
augmentations de salaires pour nos
officiers général
la démonstration a été faite et demeure
fait qu'au sein des forces armées
canadiennes pendant longtemps il ya un
espèce de deux terribles aveuglement par
rapport à un nombre qui apparaît très
élevé de comportement très très très
inapproprié et le fait qu'il y ait un
processus judiciaire dans le cas présent
ne libère rapport le gouvernement de
devoir rendre des comptes
ce qui est primordial dans cette
question de ce qui s'est passé dans les
fosses canadien c'est vraiment le
message envoyé aux femmes le message qui
étaient envoyés aux femmes c'est vous
n'êtes vous n'étaient pas écoutés vous
n'étaient pas entendues on a eu une une
cas de harcèlement sexuel qui était qui
est arrivé au bureau de premier ministre
ministre des défenses et ils ont rien
fait
nous avons reconnu depuis le début qu'il
fallait transformer nos forces armées on
a pris des mesures concrètes depuis
plusieurs années mais évidemment il
reste énormément de plus à faire comme
on le voit c'est pour ça qu'on est très
content d'avoir la maintenance générale
à carignan en train de mener à la
bataille à l'intérieur des forces bon
est-ce que ça pour cette campagne
électorale parce que l'on voit que le
discours se ressent jeu très doux dit
j'ai demandé à un lieutenant général
carignan à l'intérieur il ya aussi un
autre examen externe y en avait eu déjà
un qu'est ce que ça change pour cette
campagne alec
je suis pas certain que ça va être un
enjeu central de la campagne électorale
je pas l'impression que les gens vont
nécessairement aller voter en pensant ça
reste claque est une faiblesse du côté
du gouvernement libéral que cette
question là parce quand justin trudeau
dit on le re connue depuis longtemps
c'est vrai on a posé des actions
concrètes c'est pas vrai il s'est pas
passé suffisamment de choses dans les
six dernières années du côté du
gouvernement pour véritablement prendre
ça au sérieux on a laissé les forces
canadiennes essayer de se réformer
elle-même en se disant bon ils vont
faire salle interne ils vont laver leur
linge sale en famille puis on espère que
ça va bien se passer c'est s'est pas
bien passé ou du moins sa peau est
insuffisant par rapport à ce qu'on
savait être un problème les forces
armées canadiennes je rappelle que le
ministre la défense argy sa jambe il est
ministre depuis que justin trudeau août
au pouvoir ça fait six ans et on est
encore aux prises avec le même type de
controverse dans les forces armées
canadiennes visiblement et quelques
professeurs travaillent et c'est
probablement le ministre la défense donc
c'est pas un terrain très agréable pour
les libéraux même si j'ai pas
l'impression que ça va être quelque
chose qui vous a attiré l'attention par
une partie de la campagne il est très
bien chantal rapidement est pas là tu
chantal mais je rappelle que monsieur
trudeau dans les rues demandons qu'il
donne à ses ministres à partir du
premier jour donc chasser la commande
passes à ses ministres qu'ils n'ont
jamais dit aux ministres s'agit de
mettre en vigueur les recommandations
vous aurez porte deschamps qui était sur
son bureau sur ce sujet là le jo il est
arrivé de rendre à l'extérieur de sortir
des forces un examen complet des
plaintes paul
baysse à écorce l'image féministe de
monsieur trudeau puis ça aussi la
question sa crédibilité pourquoi lui
faire confiance de faire dans un
troisième mandat ce qui l'a pas fait
dans le premier ou dans le deuxième
c'est assez ironique en 2016 le
gouvernement a reçu le rapport des
chants dont vous parliez de
recommandations phares donc créé un
organisme indépendant pour traiter les
plaintes mais aussi pour ramasser des
données parce que c'est important et
c'est de mieux
quantifier le phénomène ils ont rien
fait à part en fin de mandat commander
un nouveau rapport qui risque d'arriver
à peu près aux mêmes conclusions et en
cas de choses encore plus ironique ils
n'ont ils ont décidé de renouveler leur
confiance dans monsieur valls alors
qu'il était et qu'il faisait l'objet
d'allégations c'est une chose qu'on veut
c'est si compliqué de démissionner
quelqu'un
il faut avoir une certaine quantité de
drogue mais de là à renouveler son
mandat on aurait très bien pu à
l'exécutif ne pas le faire et ne pas
accorder sa confiance à monsieur vince
pour gérer le dossier on a donc de tous
les crimes sexuels alors que lui même
faisait l'objet d'allégations est
vraiment un problème de crédibilité
desdits des rôles il nous reste 3 6 2
que ça
il nous reste trois minutes je veux
parler de vaccination
le nouveau brunswick s'ajoute à la liste
pour les employés de la santé le québec
l'ontario
l'ontario yosh plan b si on voulait pas
faire vacciner pour faire tester ça
devait être le plan des fédérales aussi
pour les fonctionnaires comme nous le
donner une note du conseil du trésor est
ce que ce n'est pas un bel exemple où
les détails de quelques choses sont
venues embêter sérieusement messieurs
trudeau qui pensent extenet
l'histoire de
tous les fonctionnaires fédéraux et la
vaccination avec si vous pensez que ça
embête et justin trudeau préparez vous à
ce que ça embête françois legault aussi
c'est le genre de celle chaude de
dossiers où c'est facile de dire on est
pour la vaccination obligatoire
maintenant qu'on a des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre par exemple dans un système de
santé qui est déjà à bout de souffle
comment on fait pour la faire appliquer
cette vaccination obligatoire là justin
trudeau a le même problème ça devrait
être obligatoire à ce que je vais mettre
des fonctionnaires à la porte oh là ça
devient plus compliqué est ce que je les
suspenses que dans certains secteurs ce
après causé des bris de service
non c'est une situation qui est complexe
en réalité quand on s'attarde au détail
et justin trudeau a été le premier à
s'avancer donc les premières questions
étaient vers lui maintenant ça va être
doctor droite françois legault ça va
être blaine higgs et on en a encore pour
des semaines de débats est arrivée et ce
même de débat mais même d'une journée à
l'autre depuis cinq jours c'est se
durcit d'une province à l'autre
aujourd'hui blending cc générale et
totale justin trudeau si les hangars et
pas dans un avion ou dans un train ou
dans un autobus interprovincial je vous
prédis dirait que plus les chiffres le
nombre de cas va augmenter plus le
disque au dessus alors ses
conclusions parce que là les gens qui se
sont fait vacciner deviennent de moins
en moins tolérants face à ceux qui ont
voulu faire ce geste là et on le voit
même dans le milieu de la santé on en a
pas encore beaucoup parler mais je suis
certain qu'ils aient du personnel
soignant qui ont pas le goût de
travailler à côté de gens qui ne sont
sont au fait vacciner par contre la
grande différence entre la santé au
québec qui les fonctionnaires fédéraux à
savoir c'est que la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre elle est plus vive en sortent
et qui est fait mal elle aggrave les
conditions de travail déjà très très
difficile donc un peu importe ce qu'on
choisisse à revenir avec de sérieux
problèmes avec chantal paul merci
beaucoup à très bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit